there would be no l.a food scene without
the street vendors without back of the
house workers our food industry
collapses i cannot imagine in new york
without chinatown
[Music]
just because we can't see the back of
the house workers doesn't mean that they
don't exist
[Music]
these micro entrepreneurs are selling
fruit cups because they're trying to
take care of their families
yes
chinatown businesses they're always
going to put the needs of their
community before themselves
to label them essential when they
rightfully are and not give them any
type of support what are we talking
about here that's just unjust
the food industry would not exist
without immigrant back of house workers
to us this is representative of my
family's struggle coming to america
i think that's worth fighting for don't
you
[Music]
not government funded we didn't go to
school for a social or civil justice
degree we just want to help
this is an entire community that has
been built through generations of
immigration and families and
[Music]
si
love
[Music]